hello today we're going to look at
hypertransformer this is a model for few
shot learning where you get new data
that you haven't seen before with
potentially new class labels so this
model takes in a set of data points and
corresponding class labels and its
output is the weights of a convolutional
neural network that can then be used to
classify those data points and
corresponding test data points this is
very useful because it decouples the
model that does the meta learning or the
few shot learning it decouples the size
of that model from the size of the model
that then does the actual inference on
the data which means that i can have a
big model doing all the meta learning
things and end up with a very very lean
convnet that i can deploy anywhere it's
very useful if this needs to be deployed
on mobile phones it's very useful if
there are privacy considerations
federated learning anything like this so
the hyper transformer it doesn't
classify data itself it actually
produces a model that classifies data
which is very cool in itself so the
models are quite performant by itself
they're not super good um like they're
not the best but they're good enough and
potentially they could even be used as a
starting point to then uh refine and do
some more trading so this is what we're
going to look at today this research is
by andrei schmogenov mark sandler and
mark vladimirov and i'm going to
interview andre in a bit here on the
channel he joined me and we had a nice
conversation about the paper so please
let me know if you like styles like this
i feel it's a big boost to have the
authors on with these paper reviews but
you need to tell me how to make the best
use of their time how to need to make
the best use of your time the viewers
time because i don't want to make these
videos like more long than they have to
be but also want to give you the
opportunity to sort of pick and choose
some people prefer just my explanations
some people prefer the interviews and i
view it as like a bit of a buffet but
please let me know in the comments how
you would like a paper explanation with
an author to be structured the best
because it's you know ultimately it
needs to be good for anyone watching all
right let's dive in the interview is
gonna be a market there's chapter
annotations down in the uh bar here you
just look if you want to skip to the
interview feel free so the hyper
transformer is a model and it says it
says it in the name it's a a hyper
transformer or i mean you could you
could also have called it like meta
transformer or something like this it is
a model that in itself produces weights
and what is it useful for it's useful
for few shot learning and this is one of
the things i appreciate about this paper
which i only really realized after i've
done the interview is that in just the
framing of the problem itself is very
special such that the model is quite
good at it which is maybe a lesson for
all of us in research uh to to uh to
already look for the good problem
so what we're going to end up with is
we're going to end up with a few shot
learning setting in few shot learning
you want to build a model like let's
call it model m or just some sort of an
algorithm doesn't even have to be a
model and that model m will get just a
few data points let's call let's say
these are images like okay i get in this
case four it might be some more than
four but you know a couple of dozen
images or something like this so not a
giant amount of images with their
corresponding label so let's call let's
give each one a y like each one a label
and i want to take this data set
i want to input in into this box and the
box should come up with ideally a model
so the box doesn't have to be a model
but let's call this like a neural
network over here which should then be
performant on the data that on the
distribution that this small amount of
data has come from the challenges are
obvious you only have very little data
to do this
the second challenge is that these
labels might come from classes that
you've never seen before right
they might be new classes so this is the
general task of view shot learning the
advantage is that very often the task
isn't completely new so the task isn't
like a complete surprise but the task
itself this is what it's called a a task
right here the task itself comes from a
distribution of tasks which means that
you have kind of a like a data set
that have many such tasks here so here
is a task right this is a data set
with some train and test samples each
one having their labels and then so this
is a task and then there might be
another task and another task and
another task so consider this sort of
like a machine learning problem except
the data points our entire tasks so you
want to build a model that takes in such
a task and gives you a good classifier
for that particular task now the
question is obviously how you do that
what most people do or not most people
what has been popular previously and
i've made a video for example for um i
mammal
so i mammal i think it's it's it's
written like this
l there's an l here
this is a technique about metal learning
so what you would do is you would train
one big model you train a big model
and you train it with each of you sort
of train it with each of the tasks and
what you do is you want to end up with a
model that is kind of like a common
initialization for all the models so
when you get a new task you want to take
this model and you want to fine tune it
for a couple of steps for that
particular task and if you get another
task you want to take the common
initialization you want to fine tune it
for that particular task so for each
task you'd end up with the same model
with this model right here but
fine-tuned for that particular task this
is what we do it's very popular if you
think of things like bert or so this is
essentially what we do we get to a
common initialization and then we
fine-tune that except methods like imam
explicitly train that initialization for
the purpose of then being fine-tuned to
a few short learning tasks so
potentially having new labels or
potentially the same labels the problem
is obvious the models are the same right
this model and this model right here
they're the same like architecture it's
just one is a fine-tuned version of the
other and there's the question right for
is that appropriate for the task like is
this model right here appropriate for
this task maybe you can say well maybe
not it's just a few data points in
general if i have few data points i
might want a small lean model though it
doesn't like blow up it doesn't overfit
also maybe you know where do i use view
shot learning well probably i use it
when you know i need to have a model for
every user like you have your photos
library the photos library has a couple
of dozen pictures in it now you want to
train a classifier on it right and your
classifier is going to be different from
the next user's classifier and so on so
there's no common classifier it can be
personalized and also there this needs
to like run on your mobile phone if
that's the case and then you don't want
like this giant model so we want a lean
model however if you look at the model
in the middle right here like this one
of course this needs to be big it needs
to like cover all of the different tasks
that could be and then some more right
like it needs to train on a distribution
of tasks to be able to classify tasks
that it hasn't even seen before so that
one needs to be giant
ideally as big as it can get right to
absorb all the information so there you
have the dichotomy and the weakness with
the approach of having
the same model being fine-tuned down the
road and that's why the hyper
transformer does a different thing the
hyper transformer says well i have a big
model right here and that model will
produce
the weights of the small model so
we won't fine-tune anything we will
simply forward propagate the task
through the model and then that model
will spit out the weights and we're
gonna do it in a kind of a smart way
because i believe this has been tried
before i think even i have tried it
before and it usually doesn't work and
has particular reasons why it doesn't
work among other things neural networks
are quite bad at hitting exact numbers
they're good at classifying but when it
comes to like regressing on numbers
they're quite bad also there are errors
that build up and so on we'll get into
that however what i said before the
framing of the task
now few shot learning can be
characterized in a few different ways
sometimes often it is also said well we
have like a big data set available right
big data set like imagenet or so on and
we use that to pre-train
the big model right here and we use that
to sort of prepare the model for a fu
shot learning
it this is particularly not i'm sure you
could somehow get it in there but in
this particular thing the model needs to
be able it's a transformer it needs to
be able to take all of these samples
into
its input so into its context window and
therefore it's almost like the model is
limited to an upper bound of number of
data points that it can it can input so
the framing of the task itself like fu
shot learning means you have these tasks
and every task has few samples and so on
um you know differentiate it from the
framing where view shot or meta learning
means that you wanna you wanna you get a
big data set and then you wanna fine
tune it on many small data sets uh that
distinction is a smart one if you write
a research paper right it is it is um if
you say well we're actually in this
situation and here the model makes
perfect sense right here it would be
more difficult
i i think just a lesson for people who
write research papers is the framing of
the problem is like half the battle
so how does this model actually produce
weights this is a schematic overview
over the hyper transformer method the
hyper transformer itself you can see
right right here uh not even that so the
hyper transformer itself is going to be
this box right here uh or this box right
here respectively
that produces weights of neural networks
the weights of the neural networks that
are produced are these things right here
so what's all this other stuff well the
hypertransformer needs some information
to produce actual weights remember what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a set of what they call support samples
so this is the data set
this is the entire data set in this case
we have three data points now this is a
schematic usually as i said it's maybe a
couple of dozen data points in this case
we have three data points so these are
the x's and their corresponding labels
in this case they call them c for like
class labels we call them y
so these are
data points and labels and remember you
might not have exactly seen the classes
before or you might uh this is this is
up to
sort of
the the task at hand
so what we're going to do is we're going
to feed the hyper transformer with the
data right we say you know here is a
this is the entire data set we say dear
hyper transformer this is the entire
data set please give us weights now the
question is how do we feed a data set
to the transformer and they have various
ways of how to do that
and
what they do is they want to provide
like the most accurate information to
the transformer as possible so the first
thing you see right here is that there
is a feature extractor this thing right
here it takes in a data point each one
individually and it outputs features for
it which makes sense so the transformer
can't for example read images by itself
you can't read them out of the box so we
need some sort of data extraction
pipeline so this is a feature extractor
it's going to be like a convolutional
neural network that has a few layers
that serves as a feature extractor this
can be a trained end to end this can
also be pre-trained what's important
that we end up with a vector for each
data point so each data point here
gets a vector which can then be fed into
the transformer as you would feed a
token embedding vector if you were to do
nlp the other thing is and this is not
super important in in the first layer we
also need to feed the hidden activations
of the current layer now i want to leave
this away right here because in the
first layer there's not that much of a
distinction but it's going to be
important in all the following layers
and then we also want to feed an
embedding of the class label right here
they put the class label directly but
it's actually an embedding of the class
label that is fed to the transformer so
with all of this information the
transformer sees the entire data set
it's supposed to classify and it will
output the weights of the convolutional
neural network now you see right here
it's more complicated than just
outputting the weights of the entire
conf net so what we could do is we can
say well i have a conv net with a bunch
of layers right i put my data into the
transformer and the transformer just
like boom outputs all the weights at the
same time like bam bam bam bam here's
all the weights this would be very bad
well i guess i don't know but i guess it
wouldn't work at least in my experience
because these errors they would kind of
accumulate the transformer would need to
guess from the initial embeddings right
here what all the weights are so
essentially internally it would sort of
have to model this
model in its like in it like inside of
it and then sort of guess what the
representations in here are going to be
in order to create the weights for the
layer here
if you make a mistake right here then or
a small error then that arrow will kind
of accumulate through the layers and so
on so it is quite bad advice to produce
all the weights at the same time instead
of the hypertransformer produces the
first layers weights first then it takes
the data points propagates them through
the weights that it itself had just
produced it observes the hidden
activations after that layer and then it
reconsiders these hidden activations for
producing the second layer's weights
this is all one big computational graph
you can actually model it in like
tensorflow pi torch and in the interview
we're going into a little bit of whether
that's you know feasible for larger
models and and whatnot but
that's what it does so it first produces
the weights of the first layer right
here then it forward props the model so
this this f right here that is the
resulting convent so you take the
weights of the confidence you you fuse
it together with the architecture and
that's going to be the generated layer
number one you take the data points you
feed them through the generated layer
you get the activations right here
and that those activations
will become sort of the the feature this
it says activation feature extractor so
you've got you're going to have some
hidden activations which are also going
to be if it's a conv net they're going
to be some sort of a a tensor some sort
of like a and width by height by channel
tensor so again you need like a feature
extractor but essentially what you're
going to do is you're going to feed the
hidden activations again to the
transformer along with the original data
so you're going to say here's the
original data here is the hidden
activation it has at the layer that i'm
trying to produce the weights for right
now and also again you're going to feed
the class labels so this is the totality
of the information that transformer has
available at every layer it has the
original data the hidden embeddings of
the current layer after the last layers
and the class labels and then it's
supposed to produce the next layer right
here
uh yeah this as i said the computational
graph is quite enormous right here
because if you if you think about it
right you you produce these weights
right here and then you forward prop
through these weights so any change you
do to the weights will sort of change
everything that's after uh but
andre told me that this is it is quite
possible to do with current deep
learning frameworks which is a cool
thing like imagine you had to do this
by hand like old papers they always
wrote down the gradient by hand so this
is in general the model what's possible
and what they do is they say well we
don't technically need to produce all
the weights of a cnn what we can do is
if we have like a cnn we can just use
the hyper transformer to produce like
the last layer's weights or the last two
layers weights we can still train for
example these things right here with
backprop so what happens during training
during training this thing right here is
one
task right this is one data point
essentially if you think from a meta
learning perspective so this one task
i'm going to feed through the whole
architecture at the end right here i'm
going to feed the data or these hidden
activations i'm going to feed them
through i'm going to get the labels of
the data point then i'm going to use
back propagation to train all of this so
to i'm gonna use back propagation to
train the hyper transformers parameters
possibly also the feature extractors
parameters here and here and if i don't
like this is one step and if those
things only produce let's say you only
produce the last two layers weights i
can also back propagate because the back
propagation path is like this and then
like you know like this and then so on i
can also use back propagation to train
these first two layers so the first two
layers will essentially become this this
common feature extractor like we talked
about at the beginning when we spoke
about imam or something like this they
will essentially become shared among
tasks and then it is just the last
layers that are tasks specifically
produced for that they do find in the
experiments that for small models like
if the cnn is small it pays off to
produce more of the layers like also the
filters
if the cnn however is large they say
they can get away with just producing
like the last layer which is the
classification layer so you know i don't
know whether that's a limitation of the
implementation of the method itself it
seems you know that there's errors can
accumulate and so on um the data sets
but also as i said the models should be
small so you don't even want to build
super large models
from you don't want to build super large
models right right here the ones that
you actually deploy
so that is that is the overview over the
model there is this other graphic right
here where they show how exactly the
hyper transformer does the things it
does so here what it gets as an input
are these things so there we have the
class sorry the class label embeddings
um concatenated with the sample
embeddings so that is like one token as
an input they do praise the transformer
because it's
invariant to positions right so if you
don't provide positional encodings any
permutation of the input will will
generate the same the same output
essentially so the this is one token one
token is an embedding of a sample and an
embedding of its class label the
transformer can also take what they call
no label embeddings which means they can
go into semi-supervised learning so
sometimes you have a bunch of data and
then a bunch more data that is not
labeled so they can just provide a
pseudo embedding like for an additional
class that essentially says this one's
unlabeled they do find that they can uh
incorporate unlabeled data but only to a
point like if it's too much it gets too
noisy and then these things right here
essentially these are
these are kind of requests to the
transformer
these are um embeddings for the weights
that i'd like to produce so essentially
this one right here might say i want to
produce
layer one
weights for the
convolutional filter and of that
convolutional filter i want to to
generate slice number one all right so
and then this one right here will be
slice number one of the convolutional
filter of layer one so that you
essentially with the weight embeddings
what they call right here these aren't
really weight embeddings themselves
they're like
weight
address embeddings like like like um
you know if you if you had to name the
variables in your code these are
essentially the variable names so these
are the this it's like the it's like the
cls token right you request something
from the transformer you say here is a
token and
on the output of that token i'm going to
expect you to give me a particular
result
so that is how the hyper transformer
takes in data and outputs data here is
the generated weight slices now they can
be directly the weights or they can be
some sort of an embedding for the
weights if you have to produce a lot of
weights so you can have like another
model uh that scales up whatever is
output here to the actual format of the
weights
um yeah many things possible right here
i
don't want to go too much into the
results right here uh because um as i
said one one big result is that if they
have models that produce all of the
weights right here and also this here
logits and conv like if they produce um
the log layer and the convolutional
layers this only appears to really help
if the model is small so these here
would be the smaller models which do
outperform if you only if you sort of
learn jointly the kind of layers and
then only produce the logic layers with
the hypertransformer whereas for the
bigger models this doesn't seem to make
that much of a difference anymore other
than that i don't want to go too much
into the results however the last thing
i want to explain right here is their
sort of chapter on the reasoning behind
the self-attention mechanism so they
argue
that the self-attention mechanism has
special properties that make it very
very apt at producing the
producing weights for like a for a
classifier and specifically they go into
why it could be ideal not ideal but
appropriate for producing weights for a
classification layer so i want to make
clear what's happening right here they
say theoretically or in concept the
self-attention mechanism
right here can in one single layer of
self-attention can produce a classifier
over the data samples that we give it
right this is
this is what the transformer has to do
the transformer has to take in the data
points right it has to produce
essentially let's think of the last
layer as to produce a classifier for
those data points so the question is
how does it do that there's no sgd
involved there's no training involved
right you could fine-tune but they're in
the forward prop through the transform
there's no training involved so how
conceivably can
a self-attention mechanism produce the
a classifier over data and for that they
show that even a one layer
self-attention mechanism can conceivably
produce a simple classifier how do how
does it do that
so let's think of what a classifier is a
classifier is essentially a weight
matrix and the weight matrix in the
let's say in the
um let's make a coordinate system let's
say this is the embedding space of the
last
layer so
what the weight matrix looks like is
let's say we have let's say we have
three different classes or say we have
four different oopsies we have four
different classes
so this is one two three
four or four different classes
which means that the weight matrix is
going to be like d by four
so it has one
one slice one column or
row
one column for each of the one column
for each of the classes and how is it
gonna classify well it's gonna run every
day to point x through the weight matrix
multiplied by the weight matrix
and that gives me four numbers so it's
an inner product which e with each of
the columns gives me four numbers which
is essentially the inner product with
with each of the four uh vectors right
here if x is for example here the
biggest number is going to be the one
with the largest dot product so that's
going to be this one right here and
that's going to be my class label these
are usually called logits the numbers
that turn out right here but they're
essentially similarities to the columns
of the weight matrix of the last layer
so can we produce this weight matrix can
the self-attention mechanism produce the
purple weight matrix such that at least
the training data points are classified
correctly
now in order to do that what it needs to
do is it needs to do the following for
each of the data points that we have
it has to um
the weight matrix can essentially be
constructed like this so
y here this is
y is a one hot encoding over the class
label
and e j is some embedding of the data
point and you see if we calculate this
up y is only going to be one at the ex
at the class where the data points label
is so the weight matrix essentially this
is going to address only the column of
the weight matrix where that data point
falls into
and by the sum it essentially sorts all
the data points into it's their
respective columns and within each
column it sums all the data points up so
if we do if we apply this formula then
the data points in class one are going
to be summed together or averaged
together and put into the weight matrix
in column one and the same for column
two the same for concrete that would
actually result in a good classifier
because
the classifier would just be the mean
embedding of all of the data points that
belong to this class which is you know a
reasonable classifier
in first approximation the question is
can the self-attention mechanism produce
something like this so let's ask
ourselves right here
let's uh say
let's say let's draw this again so we
have x1 y1 x2
y2
x3
y3
if you remember the self-attention
mechanism will calculate queries keys
and values for each of the data points
it will provide like it will do like a
soft max over the queries and the keys
of over an outer product of them then
multiply them by the values so the
question is this entire thing needs to
turn out to be a w like that so this
entire thing needs to
address all the data points of the same
class and then average them we can say
well that's pretty easy okay
and they say this this is what they say
in the paragraph right here they try to
make a case that this can be done so if
we take the data points and we we just
calculate we calculate their embedding
like they have some embedding function
actually we don't even need let's just
say the data points themselves are
already embedded so x
x 2 like is is the embedding of itself
so
let's say
these the data points themselves they
are
they're the values yeah let's say they
are the values then the
labels are the keys
so that means that if two data points
have the same label they will expose the
same key now all we need to do
essentially is we need to make sure that
the queries so over here we have the
weight
the the address of weight 1 and the
address of weight 2. we need to make
sure that the queries that the weights
produce
if those queries
are matching with
the uh with the keys that these expose
you can see that this all works out
so weight one would say well i am the
weight that is going to be the column
for class one i'm going to expose as a
query the embedding
which they like zai i don't know i just
to write this letter the embedding for
class one whereas these data points say
well i'm going to expose as a key
whatever the embedding
of my class label is
and now you can see that weight 1 given
that it's class 1 will aggregate all of
the different data points but only if
they expose the key of class one right
if y2 equals c1 they will aggregate
together the query and the keys will
match they will aggregate together the
values are the data points themselves so
this will result for each of the weights
in an average of all the data points
that correspond to its particular class
label that's exactly how we build the w
notice that it's not important what the
queries of the data point tokens are
it's also not important what the the
keys and the values of the weights are
as long as they don't conflict with
these queries right here
it's just a proof of concept that this
could happen
another proof of concept they do in a
similar vein is that
with respect to the unlabeled samples
remember we said we can also do
semi-supervised learning right here we
have a data point and we have no label
available for it what can be done and
they show that with a two layer
self-attention mechanism you can
actually do it such that in the first
layer sort of the labels are propagated
and then in the second layer
you can apply the same thing as right
here so how do we propagate labels again
let's think of data point x1 y1
x2 y2
and now let's think of x3
with unknown label
well what can we do what we can do is
and now we have to rethink a bit how do
we structure the self-attention
mechanism such that
label is propagated in the next layer to
this data point right here
so let's say
this data point here exposes as a query
it exposes
its
its data point like its vector it's
embedding that is going to be the query
so every every token right here as a
query exposes its um
it's embedding and also as a key
and specifically these two as a key they
expose their vector and they also expose
their embedding of the class as values
so now you can see that we're going to
match up keys and queries now let's say
these two data points here are very
similar their keys and their queries are
going to match right
and specifically since this here is the
query the value of that data point is
going to be put is going to be
aggregated in that token whereas these
might not match as much so this this
value isn't going to be aggregated so
here you can see that this is
essentially a nearest neighbor
classifier this token is going to look
which of the other data points are
similar to myself if this is really how
it's you know how the mechanism is
structured is going to look which are
similar to myself and from all of those
that are similar i'm going to average
the class label embedding for myself and
all then i need is like a residual
connection to copy over the data and uh
some orthogonality and i have
essentially aggregated class labels from
all the nearest neighbors of the other
data points that's the first layer and
then the second layer now every data
point has a class embedding and i can
just use this one to build a classifier
so this is a proof of concept that with
two layers it is actually possible to
label unlabeled data in the nearest
neighbor fashion and then build a
rudimentary classifier over like an
average embedding classifier over that
data
i hope that made a little bit of sense
we're going to talk about some
supporting experiments that are in the
appendix that actually show and we're
going to talk about this in the
interview that actually show that if
these are these two layers right in the
first layer the unlabeled examples they
attend to the labeled examples a lot and
then in the
transformer layer 2 the weights actually
attend sorry in the layer one the
weights attend only to the labeled
examples you can see they don't attend
to the unlabeled examples at all
in layer two however the weights having
already attended to the to the labeled
examples now also attend to the
unlabeled examples which means that the
unlabeled examples have gained some
information in layer two as i said we're
going to talk about this more in the
interview so what you're going to hear
in the interview is also again like a
little bit of a different perspective on
the model um we go through the
experiments we go through it means some
criticisms that i have about the model
itself
and yeah so i i realized this was a bit
of a longer explanation than usual i'm
trying these things out again let me
know what you prefer like short
introductions to the paper then an
interview or like long explanations
followed by a short or long interview
do you want to pick and choose from the
video and so on i need to know so please
tell me and as always if you like this
then leave a like comments and yeah have
fun
[Music]
welcome everyone today i have with me
here andrei schmogenov is that
approximately correct andre absolutely
correct yeah thank you thanks for having
me thank you so you're you're one of the
authors of the hyper transformer uh
paper and this is a pretty cool paper i
found uh
little like it i i do not i do not hang
it out big time but i have once tried to
publish a paper uh using one model to
produce the weights of another another
model it worked like barely so when i
saw a paper that actually does it in
practice i was like i was stoked i was
like yay this is you know um it's pretty
cool so yeah um welcome first of all and
and congrats on this paper it's i i
liked it if we
look at like the high level idea of the
paper um it is
you generate essentially use one neural
network to generate weights for another
neural network there are many settings
which that can be applied to do you want
to maybe transmit like the high level
idea of what the paper is about
yeah so so it basically started exactly
as a question can we even train a model
that generates all of the weights for
the other model but unlike hyper network
paper which we were inspired by in this
case we really wanted to
modulate the model that we produce on
the task that it's supposed to solve so
basically what we wanted is we wanted to
take a description of a task that the
model is supposed to solve
and in a single forward pass converted
into the weights of a fully trained
model and not even a subset of weights
but we wanted to take a big bite and
generate all of the weights of the model
and and the question you know from the
very beginning was is it even going to
work
uh will we get results comparable uh to
what you might get by training the model
to start with and uh the
in principle the applications we
considered a few shot learning as an
application but it really kind of the
field could be
for example personalization
and i guess like one of the main ideas
of this paper what we try to convey is
that in many cases when people discuss
future learning or
when they discuss personalization they
think of models as you know as large as
they need to be to serve all of the
potential users all of the potential
needs and here we ask a question well
what if the computational budget is
actually limited and you want to
basically to produce a model that is
very very fine-tuned to specific needs
of a specific user so basically we are
kind of trying to separate uh the
complexity of a small model that is
supposed to solve a task for each
individual kind of user
from the
complexity of a big model that's
supposed to know everything about the
world and everything about how to
generate these small models and so that
kind of was one of the main ideas that
we can separate them and we were hoping
that we would be able to capture kind of
the variety of the small models and how
they depend on the task inside this big
transformer-based model essentially the
idea seems so clear when you when you
think about it but it is so far away
when you've at least to me it was like
once i saw your paper i was like oh yeah
of course because what we were doing in
the past few years i think is and and
this started maybe with something like
bert made it really popular to like
pre-train a really big model and then
kind of just fine-tune it on on your
little data and all of these
meta-learning or few shot learning
papers they would do the same thing they
would pre-train a big model and then for
example mammal would train that same
model on the small data essentially
what they were trying to do was find
like a good initialization right to
to then continue training but
essentially the same model was tasked
with two different things the same model
was tasked with ultimately solving
all of these small tasks that you throw
at it and at the same time like finding
a good compromise between all the models
and and you separating this it makes
total sense you say well one network is
really responsible for integrating all
of these tasks and the and the other
like the smaller network that is
produced is responsible for you know
solving the individual tasks this has
lots of applications i think you
mentioned it in the paper
personalization is probably a big one
right if i just have my you know
20 30 photos in my photo library uh now
i could i could have like a small model
that is just made for me uh derived by
this by this big model so i was i was uh
it seems obvious in hindsight but i
it was to me it was not on the forefront
of my mind um so you
you i mean there are legitimate concerns
when
when you say we want one network to just
output the weights of another network um
specifically
we know that neural networks are really
good at classifying stuff
um you know outputting ones or zeros or
or into a bucket but they're not so good
at
outputting exact numbers right they're
not they're not
to the point where a lot of
reinforcement learning papers for
example they would rather bucket the
values they're trying to predict and
then predict the class of the bucket
rather than predicting an actual number
so
you know did you did you have you must
have had these concerns as well and and
how how exactly does your model like
predict the weights of another model
yeah that's that was definitely a
concern and actually as it turned out
for contribution models solving future
burning tasks that doesn't end up being
a huge issue partly because for
especially for very large models you
don't really
need to fine-tune all of the weights
very carefully
because if your embedding
is already good enough embedding model
then um in principle all you need to do
is look at the final embeddings produced
for different images and kind of based
on that figure out how you need to
assign labels to essentially these
embeddings so in practice as we've seen
all that matters for especially for very
large models that you know that can
have a very large embedding inside is to
just generate the final layer but once
you get into the land of smaller models
it's still important to um to generate
all of the layers
and one of the approaches that we use
basically what we have to do carefully
is instead of generating all layers at
once
from the inputs so the input in this
case just to clarify is the
in the future learning uh scenario you
have a support set that basically tells
you these are the images that the final
network has to classify as a cat for
example and these are the images that
the final network should classify as a
dog and then we hope that the generated
model would be able to classify all cats
as cats and all dogs as dogs and so our
model in this case would see a support
set it would see that sufficiently small
batch of images
um and instead of generating you know
like immediately layer one two three
four we
decided that we needed to generate them
layer by layer starting from the lower
one and the motivation for this is
really if you imagine that you modified
a very early layer then all of the
activations throughout the network will
be modified
and so basically if you modify the first
layer you have to then adjust all of the
rest
and
the you know the differences will
propagate and will potentially amplify
through the network and so you have to
potentially be very aware of what the
previous layer generates to actually
generate the following layer and i guess
that was one of the ideas how we could
stabilize that layer by the layer
generation
so is it
is it fair to say that you're so this
this what you call support set that is
essentially the data set
of the the few shot tasks right it's
it's like here are 10 images of dogs and
cats with corresponding labels
which in this is a diagram of your
architecture in general so this is the
support set with the samples and the
labels and then you make you make use of
lots of signals throughout the network
such that
as you said you make sure you first
build the first layer and then based on
that build the second layer so if we if
we quickly walk through it one core
component is this image feature
extractor that is a trained
let's say a convnet that is applied to
each image individually and just
extracts some sort of a feature map and
this feature map is then given to every
single computation layer in your in your
set right so your main model is this
this transformer thing here
that it takes in as you can see it takes
in these these
embeddings of the support set it takes
in the labels
obviously right it needs to know what it
needs to classify how
and
it generate takes in this thing right
here and i think in the first layer
this is kind of the same as these image
embeddings it's it's another embedding
right it's sort of it's another signal
yeah but it's it's it's basically
produced from the same images
essentially i guess we'll we'll we'll
come like this is in subsequent layers
this will actually be different so what
we do is the transformer here it will
produce the weights
of the first layer and as you said we
don't just produce the first layer and
the second and the third in one batch
but what is what seems to be really
important is now we actually forward
propagate i need a different color here
we forward propagate the the support set
through the weights we've just generated
and that will give us the next layer's
representation and then that can be used
again by the transformer to generate the
next layer's weights along with the
embeddings of the original images along
with the labels and so on so this this
sort of building up to the end seems to
be important and refeeding the
information through your own generation
is it
fair to say that it's
a little bit like an
autoregressive language model if i you
know feed in whatever i output again and
again
yeah exactly
in some version of the paper we even
wrote it this way basically but yeah
it's kind of like what regressive
process and the way that you generate
basically the next the following layer
weights
conditioned on the weights that you
already generated essentially and again
the motivation you know for this is if
you imagine yourself having images
original images and you have to generate
weights for the layer number three
convolutional layer right it's you may
have a trouble if you just look at the
images themselves but if you look at the
activations that the previous layer
gives you with the corresponding labels
you can then look at small patches of
those activations and figure out that oh
look there is this feature that is seen
in all of the images you know labeled as
one so perhaps i can have a filter
specifically looking for this in the
activations because that's what the
layer is going to operate on and that's
basically why we have to do it this way
uh when we try doing it once you know
the model is significantly less stable
yeah i mean that that is what one would
expect so i think yeah the trick here is
that every every
every step where you generate the
weights of a new layer you have sort of
all the information you have what's the
data set i'm trying to classify how does
that data set look
at the input to that layer right and and
that helps me tremendously to then
produce the weights um
this looks it looks it's two layers
right here and it looks already quite
complicated right here is like an entire
transformer all right um that and then
that transformer generates a set of
weights right and then i forward
propagate a signal
through the weights that were generated
by
using that signal as an input right so
i'm i'm imagining the computation graph
here gets pretty pretty iffy quite
freaked like quite fast and then there
is another transformer
and then i back prop through all of this
back right how does how like what's the
concerns with like stability here in in
like how how big does the computational
graph get is this a problem
uh so in practice it was not a big
problem but you're right that it grows
faster than you know generally
conventional cnn would grow and but but
here what you care about i assume is
kind of the longest path in this right
in this graph and so i assume it will
still be like it should be still
proportional to the number of layers but
it is true that like when you generate
the final layer you essentially have to
back propagate through all of the
transformers that you have right like if
you have multiple layers in each
transformer you have to propagate
through all of them but in practice this
thing was surprisingly stable to train
actually that was one of the things that
surprised me
the only issue i think is uh i wasn't
able to like when we looked at this we
weren't able really to train it with uh
anything other than sgd not that we
really you know spent a lot of time
doing this
and one of the assumptions why it could
at least partially be the case is
because when we train it the way we
train it is basically the training kind
of like you will train a
usual model where you give as input
images and you produce labels here we
give tasks which are support sets and we
produce weights but essentially since
you know like we have memory limitations
we basically do one task per batch so
it's kind of a single sample batch if
you will in that sense in a sense that
it's just one support sample so support
support batch and so that maybe that's
why the methods weren't exactly super
stable and
when you really applied other techniques
but with sgd trained absolutely fine and
we discovered like i think that some
degree one of the advantages that we
claim this method might have is that it
actually might be more stable than
mammal-based methods for example because
in mammal-like methods you really have
to back propagate through potentially
many unrolls if you want to
really apply several sgd updates
so uh here we really propagate through a
single model in that sense although you
know to some degree it's still a very
very manual layer
model and you make a particular case
that
transformers
are a good choice of model for this
particular task
why
why are transformers so good they they
have some trivial nice properties like
one of the trivial properties is that in
in the usual design when you don't and
you use any kind of masking or when you
don't use uh positional embeddings the
output of the transformer is kind of
equivalent to the inputs so in a sense
if you change the order of input tokens
the output tokens will change the same
way so it and and that's what you want
for a model like this because the order
of samples in the support set in which
you know order in which you
show kittens doesn't really matter all
that matters is that you show them all
and so that was one nice property that
it's really it can it can handle
potentially a varying number of samples
and it doesn't matter what order they
come in but another consideration and
that was you know there are prior papers
that
looked at um kind of attention-based
methods applied specifically for kind of
generating the last layer the last
logic's layer of the model
and we make a claim that
these attention-based mechanisms are
useful
specifically for sure for generating
that final logic layer
and i guess we make a distinction we say
that um
first of all when you are in supervised
regime and you know you have a label for
every sample if you
naively want to say oh you know what i
will generate the last layer by just
essentially averaging embeddings for
each
uh class
and that will be a row in my final
logic's layer because what you want to
do is when a new embedding arrives for
example you don't know yet you take a
dot product with all of the embeddings
that you know correspond to certain
classes
and that gives you basically the kind of
the the higher this dot product is the
more aligned the vectors are
the more likely you will say that oh
yeah that's probably that class
and and so one of the approaches to
generating the logits layer is basically
to average embeddings for each class
right so if you have a bunch of kittens
you take embeddings for these images you
average them and that's your uh row in
that
in that logic's weight matrix that you
produce
but
uh if you want to just average
embeddings that can be done with a
simple uh
attachment mechanism you basically you
take the output that you want to produce
that
row and you make it attend to embeddings
of all of the images labeled as label
one
and then
when you attempt to only those you only
need in the end to average their
corresponding values which will be
embeddings and you end up calculating
the average of embeddings of all of the
cats and that's what you want kind of so
that was the the very simple mechanism
that you could naively use that can also
be implemented as uh
basically as an attention based model
and you so that that is so you make
specific arguments um yeah this is the
reasoning behind the self-attention
mechanism here you show a diagram that
goes
a little bit into how exactly you you
build up this so you have um your
support set on is inputs as tokens along
with their labels or the class
embeddings let's say
you also have the opportunity to put in
data without labels which i guess is
quite often available in these tasks
so users let's let's again assume i have
my photo library right i might even
label some of the photos uh maybe with
like hashtags or i send them to my you
know i share them in some album or so
but most of the photos will have no
label so you also have the opportunity
here to just input them as well and just
say here is some data and
i think the
a lot of models benefit from kind of
like extra data just to know what the
data manifold looks like uh so that's
the the sense here but you in your
experiments you also have to be careful
how how much of those you uh you
introduce right in comparison but in
essence you can you can take this in and
then for each weight that you want to
output you have a special token so this
is this would be equivalent to let's say
the the cls token or so in
in a uh
in like a bird model when i want to
classify something i have one token per
output that i want to do they
these have different embeddings so like
they're like addresses of the weights
that i want to output and uh yeah this
this whole thing
it's it's uh then there's just just test
transformer but you have you you already
said with respect to like the last layer
that this is implementable but you also
make the case that if i have a two layer
transformer i can implement like a
nearest neighbor algorithm is um
like do you want to
maybe
just briefly what's the idea behind how
does how does a two-layer transformer
implement nearest neighbor
uh we never full disclosure we're never
really trying to implement it right like
in code but it's it's a simple construct
that hopefully is correct but the idea
was that yeah when you have labeled and
unlabeled samples again you can imagine
that you have a bunch of embeddings that
you know the label of like you know that
these are cats but you also have a bunch
of unlabeled embeddings everywhere
so naively what you might want to do is
you look at them on all unlabeled
embeddings and you'll notice that some
of them are really close to the
embeddings that you already know are
cats
so you say okay you know what i will
label them as cats because they are
suspiciously suspiciously close
and when i have to compute the final you
know clusters basically i will just
average over both uh labeled samples and
those that i just labeled because i'm
pretty sure that they are actually cats
right so that's kind of a reasonable way
to do this
uh and if you have self-attention-based
mechanism you can do it in two steps the
first step is really when you try to
propagate labels from labeled samples to
these nearby unlabeled samples
and if you remember how the right how
the self-attention mechanism works is
you can you you need to make sure that
the closeness
is based on the product of embeddings of
samples
and you can make unlabeled samples
attend to nearby labeled samples
and when when this when i'm an unlabeled
sample and i attend to all nearby
labeled samples i can basically look at
them and pool their class information to
myself
to my personal bedding so even though my
class embedding before was i have no
idea what i am
as soon as i saw several neighbors in
the embedding space i can just borrow
their embeddings
and this way be certain that i belong to
that cat category actually and so that's
kind of the idea of what the first layer
should do
and then after this is done the second
layer basically looks at specifically
the traces of this label whether it was
you know originally given to the sample
or it propagated to the sample
and as soon as i observe that all these
samples are marked as a cat or kind of a
you know a smell of a cat basically they
they borrow that cat reference i can
again i can take all of them average
their embeddings and that will be my
final kind of the centroid of the
cluster that i'm producing uh and you
know funny enough uh we didn't really
look into what exactly the transformer
does because it's really difficult but
if you just look at the attention maps
of two layers it turns out to be
suspiciously close to the mechanism that
uh how self-attention actually works on
the train model
because we see that exactly like in the
very first layer
unlabeled samples attend to labeled
samples
and at the same time weights get
information from labeled samples but at
the second layer weights actually get
something from these uh unlabeled
samples that were just updated so it
does look like this mechanism or at
least the version of it is actually
what's happening and you you have sort
of uh you do in the appendix you do a
lot of investigations into these uh into
various attention maps and so on is
there is there one you'd like to
particularly highlight yeah it's this
one basically
uh i don't remember exactly how it works
but i think in the first one the first
transformer layer
it's very awkward to describe so
basically what happens is the the top
rows are the ones that will generate
weights so basically if you look at the
for example the very top row this row is
telling you when the weights are updated
what are they looking at yeah so in this
case you can see that they are looking
at
columns corresponding to labeled samples
so it means that these weights borrow
something from labeled samples
but at the same time if you look
below
you will see that at the bottom of this
plot there are unlabeled samples and
they also attempt to label samples so uh
basically after this first layer both
the weights are updated
and the unlabeled samples are updated
somehow from the labeled sample
information
and then at the same time it's
interesting that the the
the the weights they don't care at all
about the unlabeled samples like they
learn to ignore
the unlabeled samples
that's pretty interesting
yeah and that's exactly kind of what you
would want because at this point right
these unlabeled samples really carrying
no
that much information about what you
need to generate and that's actually
maybe one of the reasons why when you
have too many of these samples the model
becomes overwhelmed and you have to
introduce them carefully you can't just
throw you know like hundreds of
unlabeled samples of this model
and then at the second layer basically
what happens is at this point you don't
care how labeled or unlabeled samples
are modified because you don't take that
information into account after the
second layer so all you care about this
transformer layer too is the top rows
it's again the weights
and here you can see that top rows
actually at the second layer attempt two
unlabeled samples but almost
fully neglect the labeled samples
yeah
which is also actually
quite remarkable that there is this
divide and
in in our opinion that basically shows
that there is this flow of information
right from labeled samples unlabeled and
then from unlabeled at the final layer
to the weights
yeah
yeah and so i mean it looks like the
weights they don't even care about the
label about the labeled samples anymore
but it is probably because they've
already gotten a lot of information in
layer one out of these label samples
right and now they're they're also
aggregating across the the unlabeled
samples do you think there might be like
some sort of
some sort of you know in in these other
aggressive models if they have causal
attention and so on do you think there
might be some smart attention mask that
you could implement
that uh would would kind of encourage
the the algorithm to behave better like
i'm i'm not exactly sure what i'm
looking for but do you do you think that
this there could be some some some smart
biases built into the attention masks
here so that we actually make the model
pay attention to the more relevant
things or that we want them to pay
attention to yeah i think actually
that's a wonderful idea actually as a
matter of fact what we do right now is
we say oh we think that's what's
happening and then we'll look at the
potential masks and we see that yes
that's mostly what's happening but
you're absolutely right that if we were
certain that we wanted to restrict the
flow of information in a particular way
we could very well manipulate
basically the masking of each
self-attention layer and this way very
carefully restrict how the computation
should actually be performed yeah you're
right that's actually a very interesting
point and like i imagine that could be
applied to a bunch of other applications
like what you just said like if you know
in advance how the information should
flow essentially you can uh yeah you can
implement this
by using proper attention masks you also
have a bunch of other
visualizations right here do you want to
uh maybe tell us a little bit about
because i just i just thought they
looked kind of funky uh what are they
what do they represent these are weights
of the actual cnn layers yeah
to be honest uh it's very difficult to
interpret them and i think i would
rather not uh
go into too much because it we really
have a hard time understanding what is
being but i think to some degree one
thing to
observe is that
first of all we discussed several ways
of generating weights and one of them
it's it's all it all ends up being how
you take the outputs produced by a
transformer and how you combine them
into single convolutional filters
if you think about this there are
multiple opportunities you can for
example take uh outputs and assume that
they are different channels
of a kernel by kernel by input channel
thing or you can assume that they are
there are k squared uh different slices
that you combine
but but each has a dimension of input
channels output channels and then you
reshape them in the k by k by input
channels by output channels
and depending on how you choose to do
that the model will have different
inductive biases actually because a very
laser transformer model for example
wouldn't probably want to generate very
different embeddings very different
tokens as output it would more likely if
it's you know maybe poorly trained would
generate very similar outputs and so if
you assume that these outputs correspond
to spatial dimensions
then you will see much more smooth
produced weights
because uh essentially right like you
treat every coordinated spatial
kind of coordinate as
different produced tokens and they are
all very very similar but if you do that
in channel channel wise then uh now kind
of the k by k thing k by k kernel can
look completely random it can like there
doesn't have to be any order they can
look like minus five plus five minus
eleven plus twelve
but um
and so that's why they will look much
more kind of um random visually and so i
think we kind of observed that but we
were also curious to see if the
generated uh kernels vary significantly
for different uh support set tasks and i
guess again we see that they vary but we
cannot interpret this
we hope to get slightly better results
like the more interpretable
but in that regard i think what matters
is that when we generate small models we
can measure the difference of training
and test tech versus when you actually
generate only the final layer or you
generate all of the layers including
compositional layers and we see that for
teeny tiny models for especially small
ones it really starts to matter that you
generate all of the layers instead of
only the final one and so that in the
future if we really want to understand
what this model does we really have to
look at these smaller models and then
the variation of kernels with respect to
different support sets will be probably
more telling what's happening so yeah
you find that in the small models you
you you fare better generating all the
weights than
if you
uh
and in the larger models the strategy is
essentially to
only train the model to produce the last
layer and then use a regular back prop
through that generated layer to
essentially learn the lower layers and
that might be
i mean that might also be like an effect
of of just the method not being like
figured out yet quite quite right like
it's it's a complicated method it seems
maybe a bit unstable especially if you
go to a larger model and also the errors
in larger model they accumulate over the
layers right you have many weights if
one is kind of off then
you know what what are you gonna do so
um yeah it's it it's it's an exciting
future it's have you thought about so
you you generate this this um you
generate this output essentially these
this weight token at the end it
generates some sort of an embedding i'm
gonna scroll for a whole bunch of time
right here no
i think i copied the paper twice i'm
sorry
um
so
this the the yeah you're going you're
going to generate for each of these
weight tokens you're going to generate
some sort of an output uh which you can
interpret directly is it also possible
to interpret this output as let's say
the embedding of a convolutional kernel
like that there be an another model like
like a gan or a vq vae or something like
this where you you essentially generate
into the embedding space of that model
and then that model can be really good
at producing like realistic filters it
just sort of needs to know what filter
to produce is that something that you
have tried or have in mind or or ruled
out as a possibility
no it's definitely something that we
have in mind because
really when we try to scale these
methods uh it becomes difficult when you
have to generate really humongous
weights and at this point yes the best
thing you can probably do is basically
have a separate model that receives
embeddings of the weights that it needs
to generate and that generated learns to
generate those weights themselves so
yeah you got it exactly right that's
basically that's one of the paths to
scale it to significantly larger models
we can scale this model even to red to
resident architectures but uh to
to maybe to speed up training to improve
like you said we don't even know for
sure if uh
the lack of the need to train lower
conveyors is a result of a that the
method is uh you know having in trouble
and i definitely have some evidence that
if we pre-trained certain parts of the
model then it trains slightly better so
there is definitely that complication of
training this thing end to end but also
it's you know it's few shots so that
every
if you train you know some model on five
classes having all of the images of
course it will perform significantly
better because in the future setting you
have only a few images per class and so
what can you do so that's another source
of maybe imperfection that results in
you not having to uh generate the the
you know the convolutional layers
but also it's that i think honestly the
classification problem is kind of simple
in a sense that you need to find
boundaries between classes
generative models for example are much
much more challenging because you have
to understand the structure of the data
manifold not just how to separate two
data faults and so i think like if you
ask me where this can become important
it will be there
so you you've made several experiments
on
oh sorry you made general several
experiments on on benchmark data sets is
could you maybe
uh
summarize what
in in your in your opinion in the
experiments like what was most striking
to you what stood out the most like
what's the the main conclusion you you
pulled out of there uh yes so uh i think
one of the conclusions was that yes when
we generate small models
uh we can potentially perform better
than you know mammal based methods for
methods that we train a small embedding
and then try to just generate the final
uh layer by you know using um
again like that dot product method for
example averaging embeddings finding
clusters so we definitely because we
have such a large model generating a
smaller model we have a lot more
capacity to learn about the world and
when we generate a small model we are
much more informed than say a mammal
model would be so we definitely think
that for smaller models there is an
advantage of doing what we do a
significant bump in accuracy and
especially in the training accuracy
which might matter if what you care
about is uh basically specialized model
assuming that the classes are seen
during training because generalization
is i train on cats and dogs but i
generalize to new unseen classes and
that's that can be complicated but when
you know for sure that you need to
specialize for a user
their model to work on some of the
classes that you saw during training
then what you care about is the training
accuracy and because we have such a big
model we definitely get much much higher
training accuracies
so that's about this so basically again
for smaller models there's definitely an
advantage of doing this uh when it comes
to very large models we see that when we
generate just the last logic's layer we
get competitive results to a lot of
different methods that try to carefully
design those functions
and and the methods that they use so you
know without doing anything we basically
we are kind of comparable uh so that was
again encouraging um and the final thing
that to be honest that i personally
found very very exciting is that
i think of this as
having a potential to move to very very
abstract task descriptions so in future
learning your task description is
essentially look these are several
images you should label as cat these few
images you should label as dog etc but
in one of our examples we uh add
unlabeled samples right and that
improves the accuracy quite a lot so i
was very excited to see that
you know we can get a very significant
bump in the model accuracy by giving it
unlabeled examples so somehow without us
telling how it should use unlabeled
examples it learned to use them but in
the future you could also imagine using
a lot of other types of data you could
provide like you mentioned
photo method data hashtags which might
be sparsely available for some images
for example you could have textual
descriptions for example of what people
are interested in and so on and so forth
and that would be a task description
from which your model learns to generate
a model very well aligned with the
interests of that particular person for
example
so i am kind of personally very excited
about this and i think that
that performance on semi-supervised task
and the fact that the model learned what
to do in that case
is potentially the most interesting
yeah and i didn't mention another thing
is basically what we already covered is
that for smaller models you don't only
care about generating the last logics
layer but you seem to benefit from
generating all of the confluence as well
and it it still remains to see if there
is a big difference versus generating
something like film layers
but i'm hopeful that generating as a
matter of fact all of the layers full of
them full full of weights is uh kind of
important
cool
um yeah i think that was i mean i've
i've looked at the at the results i was
i was positively surprised i mean it's
not
you know it's not at the level yet where
it's like you know we can generate like
the state-of-the-art imagenet models but
it's not necessary like i think it's
important to keep in mind that this
these models they're supposed to be
deployed somewhere where i have very
little data right i just want to kind of
produce a small model uh for for that
little data maybe in personalization
right the model even doesn't even have
to be big because it may maybe you know
on my phone or something like this and
there's definitely also i think
opportunities in the future to combine
this thing with um
i should say to combine it with
optimization right it's not it's not
necessarily a binary choice between i
generate the weights or i you know like
mammal i optimize from some checkpoint i
can also you know maybe find clever ways
of combining it but i i really like the
approach of of the paper uh right here
yeah is there i don't know is there
anything else you you want to say about
this general research direction anything
people if people want to dive into this
you know where can they go what can they
who can they do what are like you know
big open questions that
you're not considering researching so so
you know
people don't scoop you
but that's okay well i i do think that
i i think we are still actually
interested in this research direction
and we think that this particular model
could be scaled and could be applied to
other problems as well and that it could
potentially again shine either in
circumstances where you have a limited
computational budget or where you have
very complex tasks like generative tasks
um but overall yeah i would say that
some of these ideas are not new and if
somebody wants to just
know what people have been doing in that
regard like for example what you just
mentioned leo paper does something
similar where they also have a
generation of model layers but at the
same time they also use mammal approach
essentially so they kind of back
propagate through the generator of um
yeah essentially through the generator
in a way so it's it's kind of similar to
our approach
joined with uh mammal
uh but there are other techniques that
generate weights and uh i i think that
hyper network uh
original paper is really interesting and
it gave rise to a lot of interesting
research and there were recently papers
that looked into generative models that
uh
also looked at hype that were inspired
by hyper networks and honestly i think
that
um
yeah in the future we might see models
that generate other models and that
actually works in practice
um
let's see yeah so i i
to be honest it's very difficult to say
what what else can be done but one of
the things that maybe people will scoop
me but what i'm interested in is i was
just thinking about this is we can also
generate not just weights of the you
know cnn models we can generate policies
as well for example uh and and
like as a very simple example which is
very toyish but could be interesting is
for example you have a robot that you
build you take a few photos of it and
you upload them and uh to this service
and the service basically is tasked with
having several images of the robot and
having maybe images of the two running
that it's supposed to walk on just
generate a locomotive you know
controller policy for it just just like
that just from images and so i i think
that
doing things like this might be
interesting again
one thing to note is that
model distillation and training and
combining these methods with training
might be very very interesting as well
and probably
can can be you know can beat or be
compatible with methods like this but um
i i think that's one direction where the
future is generating uh models from
specifications of what needs to happen
instead of necessarily just training
them
from scratch
cool well in this case uh andre thank
you so much for for being with us here
this was awesome thank you for your
insights and i hope to see you again
with uh with a
a transformer that generates an even
bigger transformer
thank you very much yeah thanks for
thanks for inviting me and
it was very interesting to discuss this
paper actually with you
[Music]
you